good morning John so couple of days ago
the internet was on when you and me John
we were like because being on the road
makes you exhausted and we were just
were just kind of out of the loop but
obviously a small business owners and
employers and copyright holders you and
I are both very opposed to SOPA and PIPA
made a video about this like two months
ago of course because we are so
extraordinarily ahead of the curve here
on vlogbrothers who watch that click on
this marvelous one-man band we are here
in New Orleans we played a show last
night in a freaking synagogue which is
weird but of course also awesome and now
you're at some conference thing and I
have free time to walk around the city
get marvelous food with my wife and look
at the street performers I freaking love
street performers John they remind me
the Internet you never know what you're
gonna find you don't know whether it's
gonna be amazing or horrible sometimes
what they're doing borders on illegal
it's often very freaky and yeah much of
the time they're using copyrighted
content the internet is like a street in
the French Quarter of New Orleans except
that it's infinite it can be accessed
from anywhere and every street corner is
the same distance away from you at all
times and just like a street in New
Orleans there may be a lot that's going
to offend the person of average
sensibilities and if something goes
wrong and people are in danger we can
count on the government to protect us in
any system things are going to happen
that we don't anticipate and that are
bad and that are wrong we have to deal
with those things on an individual basis
but sofa isn't about the government
protecting people sofa is about the
government protecting these new sorts of
people which we used to call
corporations nudists can't regulate an
infinite street the way that you can
regulate it normal street in normal
world John I know that you and I
understand that this world needs healthy
economies but healthy economies are not
created by propping up old economic
systems at the expense of new ones
traditional media companies are rightly
scared out of their mind but not because
we're stealing their stuff but because
we and many other people on the internet
are creating a new sort of content for
smaller markets that challenges their
monolithic business models and if we
hadn't stopped this BS if we don't stop
it now who knows if in the future we'll
be able to have these marvelous outlets
for amazingly creative people to make a
living doing
stuff today John I'm extremely proud of
this infinite Street that we call the
Internet that we could band together an
amorphous anarchy becoming a solid block
in the face of this threat and basically
just cast it aside Thank You internet
Thank You President Obama thank you
nerdfighters and John I will see you
momentarily
[Music]
you